this is Hudson Yards late in 2019
Facebook completed a lease for over 1.5
million square feet of space across
three buildings in the area amazon also
has an office down the street and if you
go further down the Hudson River you'll
find a cluster of buildings leased or
owned by Google it seems like everyone
in tech wants a piece of New York City's
West Side there's a reason that most of
the major big tech brand platforms are
based in a few places they want to be
near each other and they want to be near
some of the same resources
mark Moreau is a fellow at the Brookings
Institution a Washington DC think-tank
he and other economists call this
clustering agglomeration agglomeration
is the tendency of economic activity to
gather or cluster or clump together it
happens because there are often benefits
to businesses workers and institutions
being close to each other that
clustering can build up an economy but
there's a catch even the winners don't
feel like winners if you're in traffic
choked expensive San Francisco you don't
feel like the current clustering is
working for you and neither does anybody
else in the United States and in the
heartland to understand how an
agglomeration gets going consider New
York City tech clusters typically rely
on a robust pool of workers and the
labor pool in New York is more educated
than the national average analysts say
that has become difficult to find
qualified workers in hot spots like
Silicon Valley which makes New York
attractive for expansion experts say
that labor is key obviously we've seen
these clusters develop you know all over
the world
the reason they occur is because when
you draw people together
they learn from each other capacity for
growth on the far west side grew in the
2000s during Michael Bloomberg's run as
City Mayor Doctoroff
was his deputy we did a hundred and
forty separate rezoning of the city
often of old underutilized industrial
land that opened up the capacity to
develop all sorts of new areas so we
embarked on a massive expansion of
capacity for space the city also
extended the subway for the first time
in 25 years one of the big problems on
the west side of Manhattan was there was
no great way to get over here three
billion dollars was invested in the
extension of the subway into the area as
well as other infrastructure also the
city provided land and millions of
dollars for a new Cornell tech campus
Cornell tech plays a crucial role in the
New York tech ecosystem oftentimes what
the research really shows is that
universities catalyze that kind of
collaboration better than almost any
other institution all this new
development laid the groundwork for tech
companies to open offices on the west
side forming a cluster of highly skilled
workers a big agglomeration
of say high tech economic activity it's
simply going to be more productive and
more competitive than others because it
think of what it it has close proximity
highly specialized workers highly
specialized
providers of business services research
for mr. Miro and others suggest that
workers who live in these clusters tend
to be more productive than those who
don't
here's a chart that measures output per
worker by industry group workers and
industries like manufacturing or retail
tend to be more productive if they're in
a top cluster that advantage stretches
further if you're a worker in an
innovation industry the effects are so
potent that some of the cities who have
generated clusters are pulling away from
the rest of the country
but that poses challenges for Americans
both in and outside the clusters you
only have to look at the complaints of
people who live in Seattle or the Bay
Area to see the very serious negative
implications of excessive or poorly
managed agglomeration like the tech hubs
in Seattle and San Francisco New York
has issues with affordability late in
2019 the median home in New York City
sold for 563 thousand dollars which was
much higher than the national median a
similar story unfolds in the commuting
data most states in the New York
metropolitan region have commute times
well above national averages and in the
city proper commute times are on the
rise in some cases tech workers aren't
enough to make the pain worthwhile and
that's encouraging educated people to
leave smaller cities in the big coastal
cities wages and employment levels are
outpacing other parts of the country
near future we have 9,000 startups in
New York City it's increasingly true
that every company is a tech company
whether you're in finance whether you're
in real estate whether fashion media you
name it all these sectors are already
headquartered here and they need people
who understand and know how to build
technology in regions further from the
top incomes and employment levels aren't
keeping pace which sends a message for
the foreseeable future to really have a
great career in tech in America you
probably do need to head out to the Bay
Area or New York or Seattle and work
under one of the big tech Titans I think
that's an unfortunate reality in the
United States
you